Channing, you have a tradition of
taking something when you're on a movie set,
just as a memento.
Did you take anything from this one?
I took the belt buckle.
(audience cheers)
But I do have a tradition that I take
whatever the last outfit that I'm wearing
in whatever, on the last day.
Right.
I take it,
even if it's the (bleep) sock, I'll take that home.
(audience cheers)
That's it.
That would be the covering for the genitalia
during a movie in which you reveal a lot of yourself.
That's it, cause I feel like
it's weird, because if I don't take that,
then they're gonna give it to somebody else
and not tell them.
(laughing)
That's just, that's not.
Who can wear it?
Yeah. (laughs)
A door man.
(laughing)